and there was a whole thing remember
yeah yeah we talked about it because we
were genuinely frightened you know and
they were pissed that we were
frightening yeah yeah yeah
sorry i'm scared in a scary movie yeah
yeah right [ __ ] me crazy
these [ __ ] people
you know
that's like my studio there's a there's
this yoga will say it again at my studio
you have a studio where i make music
wait you have your own studio yes
okay stop i have to make music i
understand you make music right but just
the way you say it you know what i mean
i have a studio i know it's just like
you know apartment it's like me saying
no
that's great where's the studio at it's
not an apartment
where's it at i can't say i mean just
what general town what if what if people
start going to exactly the place i'm
talking i know i don't say like the
address but like west hollywood i don't
think there's that many yoga studios in
front of
studio studio in front of my studio yeah
but there is the
and
the people there are
insane why you know how people that do
like when you do yoga you're supposed to
get more relaxed these people heckled
the [ __ ] out of us
like if there's any trash near my place
they just come over and they're like i'm
gonna [ __ ] call the landlord right
now if this [ __ ] isn't picked up no yeah
do they know who you are
no who cares i it's about it's just i'm
bringing it back to the people that were
like wait wait we're in a scary movie
you should
and then you're a yoga studio you should
be chill about everything
don't come harassing me and screaming
[ __ ]
the people that own it or the people
that go there they rent just like i do
yeah yeah or lease yeah whatever it is
you know that term the same thing
yeah why are there two names for renting
and leasing
when they do the exact same is there a
difference so what you're basically
yeah you can you can't rent a car you
can rent a car yeah it's different than
leasing a car i honestly think there is
renting's more expensive yeah i don't
know what leasing means i never learned
it's like the with the watch the clock
thing with the hands
you know i can't tell time with the
clock
right and people try to explain it to me
and i refuse to learn but you're
refusing though i know i refuse to learn
what leasing is as well
okay i know what it i my parents are on
the store yeah but i they used to use
the word and i never asked what what is
it
i learned i'm willing to learn now it's
like renting he just said it it's just
one and the same so when i'm leasing a
car
right office space right if i'm leasing
a car
dylan yes
i can
drive it brand new
how much does that cost to me
depends on the apr yeah i mean if you're
getting a toyota corolla you can get it
as low as 230 dollars a month yeah right
and then after 12 months i'm like i
don't want to lease this anymore you can
send it back stop the contract uh no you
you have if you have low amount of miles
i think but it has to be closer to when
your end your lease is ending yeah and
then they'll get they'll take it back
and then
and then you can lease a new one yeah
wow and and then what do they do with
that car they shoot it at the moon
that's how there's so many craters up
there really yeah they're all hyundai's
and
rav4s that's what those craters were you
[ __ ] [ __ ] science alert elon
musk [ __ ] [ __ ] man are you good
about are you good about returning
rental cars yeah oh no yeah no what's
the longest you've kept one and what's
what's the highest overage charge you've
ever spent well i just want to know if
you can beat bob this is a good story
though i forgot to get the insurance
when i was yeah
always get the insurance on a rent-a-car
always it's the worst lesson i've ever
learned
i uh
i was parking the car and it and this
fence just
somehow i wasn't even going fast and it
i don't know it speared straight through
the door no straight through the door